دعونا نلقي نظرة على العدد الأخير من جلين كيسلر لتصريحات
ترامب الكاذبة والمضللة ،
أصبح الرقم نهائيًا اعتبارًا من يوم
الأربعاء
30573 ادعاءات كاذبة أو مضللة
، وكما يمكن للناس أن يروا في الرسم البياني ، فقد
ارتفع الرقم بمرور الوقت بحيث أصبح الكذب
أكثر حدة في كثير من الأحيان.  الوقت فقط
يمكن لطبيب نفساني أن يشرح لنا
سبب ذلك ، لكن جيم الآن بعد أن
نتطلع إلى الأمام ،
لقد عدت إلى العاصمة ، ولا يوجد
مكتب في شاطئ النخيل حتى أن
فوكس لم يقم بإنشاء مكتب مار a-lago
، يبدو أن الصحافة لديها  في الغالب انتقل إلى الأمام
وهذا تقييم عادل أعتقد إلى
حد ما نعم ، أعني أنني أعتقد أن ترامب
أه سيقود على الأقل حركة هامشية
في هذا البلد عندما يبلغ من العمر
34 عامًا ،
فهو حقًا ليس لديه القدرة على
قيادة  الحزب السياسي الرئيسي والفوز
بالرئاسة ، يحاول أن يقارن نفسه بـ Grover
Cleveland لكن Grover Cleveland كان لا يزال يتمتع
بشعبية
عندما فاز بالولاية الثانية غير المتتالية
في المنصب ، لن يتمكن ترامب
من القيام بذلك
حيث كان  nds في الوقت الحالي ولكن استمع
إليك ، أنت تتحدث عن جلين كيسلر وبعض مدققي
الحقائق التي كانت موجودة هناك
مدقق حقائق رائع في CNN مثل دانيال
ديل
نحتاج إلى تخصيصها في مؤسساتنا
الإخبارية أه بعض الموارد
للتحقق من هذه الأفكار الهامشية التي
ستحدث  للاستمرار في الوجود في أقصى
اليمين في هذا البلد
أه بريان الذي يستمر في تمثيل
إشعال
أه الذي تعرفه أطلق ما
أسميه نار الجنون
في السادس من يناير ونعم أعني أن دونالد
ترامب سيستمر كما أسمي
هو سيد الأكاذيب
أه وبينما هو يلعق
جراحه في مارالاغو ، إلا
أنه لا يزال يشكل تهديدًا على هذا
البلد وأنا أعلم أن هذا ليس الوقت المناسب
لإلغاء مدقق الحقائق لدينا
بطريقة ما  منكم يعرف
أه الصندوق الموجود على الرف أه هم سيحتاجون
إليه للتحقق من هذه
الحركة
التي تعرف أنها لن تذهب بعيدًا ، ربما
يذهب ترامب بعيدًا ، ليس كما تعلم
بريان
أنا أتفق مع هذا أه تمامًا
شكرا جزيلا لك  على كل ما قمت به
تراهن شكرا